über diese schmutzigen geschäfte hat die
baslerin monika roth ein buch
geschrieben
kaum jemand weiß genau was hier
verhandelt wird
genaue preise kennt man nicht und mit
welchem geld die käufer die kunst von
der wand kaufen bleibt oft ebenso unklar
es ist die art basel wo jedes jahr die
gilde der kunsthändler auf die großen
kunst investoren treffen
und wie er dabei nun zusehen können die
art basel und dessen direktor marc
spiegler sehen sich als eine art
handelsplattform es ist sehr einfach wir
verkaufen quadratmeter sie verkaufen
kunst
es gibt keine transparenz über verkäufe
über verhandlungen oder geschäftspraktik
der kunstmarkt ist einer der wenigen
unregulierten märkten
deshalb setzt er sich auch immer wieder
den vorwurf der intransparenz aus
einfall hat dieses jahr für schlagzeilen
gesorgt der kunstberater helge achenbach
wurde zu sechs jahren haft verurteilt
weil er beim verkauf überhöhte preise
verlangt hatte für die anwältin und
finanzspezialisten monika roth ist der
kunstmarkt sehr anfällig für illegale
praktiken bis hin zur geldwäsche sollte
finanzkrise fließt vermehrt geld in den
kunstmarkt eine handvoll superreiche
überbietet sich an auktionen mit
spitzenpreisen wie unlängst die 160
millionen dollar für einen giacometti
die auktionshäuser sind dabei kaum
regeln unterworfen und sie können so auf
preise beeinflussen
das heißt sie können sammlung wo sich
interessierte für bestehende war könne
sie bevorzugen den damen sieht was wir
da gemacht in damals alt war als bier
durch auftritt wo das ganze etwas so
wird burton on the water die
insiderinformationen angebot machen und
schon machen sagt schlimmsten für so
viel mehr weiss vorzeitigen verfall und
da muss ich sagen dass ich weder in den
banken das thema in trance konflikt eher
große studien ausgelöst
ein anderes thema sind die zollfreilager
eines der größten ist dasjenige in genf
hier lagern hochkarätige kunstwerke
manchmal jahrzehnte lang ohne dass man
deren wert genau kennt einige dieser
werke sind auch an der art basel und
werden sie dort verkauft kehren sie oft
als wertanlage hierher zurück und
bleiben steuerfrei dann muss man halt
regeln aufstellen wo man wisse wie viel
geld ihnen gott was das wert ist wenn es
ihnen gut wewel besitz eigentümer
wachsen will mehr dokumentiert
roth fordert aber auch dass für die
kunsthändler striktere regeln gelten
müssten wenn es darum geht verdächtige
geld quellen offenzulegen
so wurde der kunst händler helly nahmad
letztes jahr in den usa verurteilt weil
er einen der größten illegalen
bettringer aufgezogen hatte
derselbe helly nahmad sitzt jetzt einen
monat nach absitzen seiner
freiheitsstrafe als händler derart bars
im zusammenhang mit dem verdacht auf
illegale tätigkeiten von helly nahmad
wurden in der schweiz 2013 gelder
gesperrt
das ist für monika roth grund genug
genauer hinzuschauen gibt es regeln an
der art basel um dubiose kunsthändler
auszuschließen wir haben regeln und die
regel ist wenn eine behörde jemanden
verurteilt werden wir das anwenden indem
wir leute ausschließen aber wir sind
keine privat geführte aufsichtsbehörde
das ist nicht unser job
immer lauter wird der ruf nach mehr
transparenz und griffigeren regeln die
kunstbranche selber wird sich kaum
darauf einlassen doch der druck von
außen nimmt zu
wenn sie mehr erfahren wollen über den
kunsthandel und seine und